[Musique]
voilà donc on va commencer soit oui du
coup je voulais juste qu'on fit et du
fait qu'on soit tous ensemble pour vous
dire que ben voila je chante the gods
c'est nous du pied leur a dit non cela
ne faisait pas clairement quand tu viens
de vous dire je fais une caméra cachée
et tu dis là en rentrant tu nous dises
fait de caméras cachées de concert tu as
tu sais pas où elle est cachée
bon c'est ce qui veut dire c'est que
c'est pas le principe d'une caméra
cachée dans la partie cette action les
caméras personnes
on s'en fout d'où elles sont une nous a
dit que tu nous piéger donc c'est pas de
caméra cachée ça marche parce que vous
ne savez pas le cacher c'est une caméra
cachée galère à la chine qui
fonctionnent avec des chantiers se passe
au t4 caméra tu les as catch et on ne
sait pas où elles sont on est d'accord
mais le principe d'une caméra cachée se
passe seulement vous cacher la caméra
cachée des thérapeutiques au buzzer
valentin avec ses mots à lui qui ne sont
pas parfaits en tout cas c'est que on
s'en fout d'accord ça complètement à la
réunion et gère des blagues
non non mais sérieux que quand même je
ne savais pas où elles sont cachées donc
en soit j'ai gagné le tie up [__] mais
ça ne va pas du tout juste la jce ici
l'intégration des sourds de reprendre le
son du canon
comment cette [__] de toi
trois chaises donc pas mon texte une
part les mimos rose surtout que les bars
à la police alliance a pour elle
rigole